la duma ha llevado a cabo la aprobación
inicial de la ley que impedirá
desacreditar según el gobierno a Los
mercenarios rusos de Wagner por ejemplo
que están luchando ahora mismo en el
este de Ucrania en el lado ruso en
realidad la ley es una ampliación de la
que existe hasta ahora que castiga con
penas de hasta 5 años el mero hecho de
desacreditar según el gobierno a las
fuerzas armadas rusas y con hasta 15
años si se difunde información falsa a
sabiendas sobre las actividades del
ejército ruso en Ucrania en torno a
5.000 expedientes se han abierto ya en
la justicia rusa por delitos de supuesta
desacreditación de los
militares rusos en Ucrania esta ley que
se amplía ahora para todos Los
mercenarios era una petición del jefe de
Los mercenarios wagnerios Gary que había
pedido que sus hombres estuviesen a
salvo de las críticas de la opinión
pública